[Musik]
das ist mir alles nicht schnell genug
ich suche etwas härteres sondern 08 15
hausfrauen sadomaso nummer habe ich ja
zu hause
ich suche den ganz speziellen kick okay
dann vielleicht ein bisserl exotischer
zb mal war und sehr lässige raubkatze
sie zählt jede noch für jeden titel ich
war mir die füße ein sack doch ich
brauche etwas härteres nicht so eine
faschingsprinzessin mit der kinderkrippe
da wenn dies sollte aber genau das
richtige für sie die dominante dominique
schmerz ist jetzt zweiter vorname ich
verspreche dass sofort schluss mit
lustig klagen weil
brauche es brutal ist was erbarmungslos
ist das muss so hart sein dass man sich
nie wieder davon erholen das muss mit
allen sinnen weh tun was unseren da
hinten drin gar nichts das hängt clowns
mit es ist das absolute grauen das kann
ich ihnen wirklich zu müssen vielleicht
ist der spezielle kind denn ich suche
ich zahle jeden preis 500
was verstecken sie da machen sie mal die
tür
das ist das schlimmste was ich jemals
gehabt und nichts für schwache nerven
kann einiges vertragen und machen sich
auf
das ist der herr nähert witz ja
und er ernährt wird dies die aktuellen
zugverspätungen der deutschen bahn vor
der
halle und bitterfeld magdeburg über
dresden
rund 450 verfall zwischen 20 minuten
ece walter ulbricht beim balzen
hoyerswerda überlebt was überlebt stadt
verspricht wie man schreibt bleibt der
ece weil der ulbrich vom ball
[Applaus]